hi
everyone thank you for joining the
webinar today
my name is anthony tong and i am a
director of product management
at bgi americas my webinar title is
automated solutions for sas cov2
variant identification and surveillance
today i will talk about a few different
aspects of sasko v2 barriers
start up with the variance diversity and
detection strategy
followed by the bgi and mgi's
integrated workflow for the virus
detection
and variant differentiation
in addition i will discuss bgi
source cov2 variant differentiation
efforts
joining me will be sabu linker who will
talk about our contributions
to amazon's most recent emergency use
authorization in covi 19 testing
solution
he will also discuss the latest events
in lab automation
for cov19 testing
several stars variants are circulating
globally
the most prominent variants of concern
are the b117
b1351 and p1 lineage
according to the cdc as of april 6
2021 more than 16 000 cases of b117
variants
have been reported followed by the b1351
and p1 lineage
for b117 you can see that there are six
states
that have gotten more than 750 cases
reported
for b1351
the situation is much better and 14
states have no cases reported and the
risk
had up to 150 cases
looking at p1 which is a branch of the
b1128 lineage you can see that
half of the states already have up to
150 cases reported
this is a brief summary of the variance
of concern
the star's cov2 variance differs spread
around the world
as long as b614g
the b117 variance also known as the uk
barriers
carries a mutation in the spy protein
and phi co1y that affect the
confirmation of receptor
binding domain rbd
this variant has 18 other b117
lineage defining mutations
let is known as b13 by one
we first emerged in south africa
and p1 which arose in brazil
both of these variants have the same
n5co1 mutation
as the b117 variance
and they also share the same e4a4k
mutation
another key sg mutation for b1 3 by 1
is k1 ek-417n
collectively these variants we see here
potentially make coffee more
transmissible
reduce antibody binding immune
protection
as well as vaccine at efficacy
the figure here not only give another
picture of the mutations
in the rbd that i mentioned on my
previous slide
such as n501y e4
a4k and k1417n but also the deletion
in the amino terminal domain ntb
here i want to draw your attention to
our deletion at positions
69 and 70 that evolve spontaneously in
other south cov2 variants
and is hypothesized to increase cove
transmissibility
pcr and ngs are the two most
common strategies used to identify
the susco v2 mutations
pcr has surface advantages
as the instrument is found in most
molecular diagnostic labs
the workflow is rapid and simple
being cost effective and highly
sensitive
and the result interpretation is easy
however the disadvantages of pcr
include detecting a small number of
known mutations
having no variant resolution and
scalability
ever as virtually no discovery power
looking at ngs this strategy
has high throughput and scalability
in a highly sensitive it had high
barrier resolution
and strong discovery power
however legend sequences
are not always found in molecular
diagnostic lab
nga is also more expensive and have a
longer term runtime than pcr
dedicated bioinformatics is also needed
i want to note here that autopcl
appear to be superior to ngs
for south cov2 mutation detection
the world health organization have
recommended the use of ngs
to confirm the mutations identified by
tcr
to address the need for detecting the
emerging sas cov2 mutations
bgi had launched a variance id panel
this panel consists of three mutation
detection keys
which are for research used only at this
time
this kit did have many detection that i
mentioned on my previous slides
testing 50 samples per key for samples
collected by
phone swap and sputum
the test has also been validated on quan
studio 5
7500 fast and light cycle of 480.
users can also use rna extraction key
from mgi
and kaioshin
speaking of the sa features bgi
variant identification kit is based on
the arms qpcr
with human beta acting as an internal
control
the kit is manufactured in bgi iso
compliance and high volume production
facility
qc is also stringent with positive and
blank controls
users can bundle this kit with bgi
rtpcl kit for detecting the coronal
virus and its variance
the figure here show our variant
identification workflow
where you can see after the samples are
collected
the user can use the mgi key to extract
the viral rna
and they use a bji kit to run rt pcr
for detecting the soft cov2 mutations
instead of manually preparing the
reagent for extraction
and pcr the users have an option
to use the sp960 system to automate the
reagent preparation
my colleague sabu will tell you more
about this system later in this webinar
once the pcr reagents are ready the user
can run the reactions
in one of the pcr machines that you see
here and finally proceed to data
analysis
and reporting
using the mgi sp960 automation system
give the labs two main benefits
first of all the system can proceed can
process
the reagent for 192 samples in 80
minutes
secondly the system only takes a total
of 2.8 hours from
rna extraction to data analysis
for 36 to 96 samples
comparing to the turnaround time of 3.5
hours
by preparing the reagents manually
the automation saved the lab about 0.7
hours in other words approximately
42 minutes
bgi sasco v2 variant id keys
offer multiple benefits
the user can bundle the purchase of this
kit with bgi
sas cov2 detection kit
the two type of keys require very
similar lab settings and procedure
later in this webinar i will tell you
more about this high competitive
compatibility
the mutation detection kits are also
highly sensitive
with a lod of 1000 viral copies per
milliliter
another advantage as i mentioned
previously in my talk today
since our mutation detection key use pcr
only
no engine instrument and bioinformatics
are needed
continuing on the previous slide
our reputation keys have a fast
turnaround time
rt pcr itself only takes one hour
lab can also run the detection essay in
a high frequent manner
with our easy to use reagents and easily
interpret the results
going back to one of my slides i
mentioned that
user can handle can bundle this kit
with bgi rtpcl kit for detecting the
corona virus
at its barriers
with that said here you can see our
rtpcl keys for detecting the coronal
virus
this kit has been authorized by the
usfda
for in visual diagnostic use by the
emergency youth authorization
commonly known as eua
the eua applied to the kofi 19 testing
workflow
with three components that i highlighted
here in three red boxes
and they are the mgi rna extraction kit
the bgi rt pcl key and the
sp 960 automation instrument
although not covered by the eua
lab also had the option to use the mgi
stp 7000 automation instrument
to enhance sample transfer including
tube decapping and recapping
barcode identification and liquid
transfer
from sample to result this workflow
using the mgi
sp960 automation system only takes 3.3
hours for processing
up to 192 samples
80 minutes for reagent preparation
1 hour 25 minutes for pcr
and 25 minutes for data analysis and
reporting
for lab that use the iot pcr sas core
feed 2
detection kit which have received the
eua
and the varying id keys which are ruo
for the same
samples the user will find audi keys
very similar in their utilities
in the table here you can see that both
of them can be used for the same sample
types
and rna extraction kit
when preparing the pcr reagents
the user will notice that the procedure
for getting their reaction mix
enzyme mix and controls are also similar
in terms of the equipment the same set
of pcr machine and automation
instrument have been validated to use
for testing the virus
and its various
here i want to emphasize that despite
the synergy
in using this kit together the variant
id keys
can be used independently without using
the coronavirus detection kit
in february this year the fda
publisher policy for evaluating the
impact of viral mutation
on coffee nothing test and a guidance
for test developers
as well as fda staff
and we know some of the mutated viruses
spread more easily
and faster than others identifying
variants in the population and tracing
their origin
have become a top priority in the battle
to contain the cov19 pandemic
a test developer bgi has stepped up its
surveillance
effort we primarily consist of
number one monthly review of article and
public health reports
number two our monthly in silico
analysis
and number three our quarterly
functional validation with red lab
testing
every month our r d team review
published
articles news and public health reports
to identify emerging mutations and
assess their potential
inference based on where these mutations
are found
and whether they overlap with the
mutations targeted by
our varying id keys
meanwhile our r d team downloads
all south profit2 genomes published in
gis aid
we stand for global initiative on
sharing
avian influenza data
in order to compare the targeting
sequences in these genomes
with respect to the primer and prop
sequences
associated with bgi sars cov2
varian id case
using the information taken by the
literature review
and in silicon analysis our rnd team
analyzed the theoretical impacts of
these mutations
on our sas cov2 detection kit
though mutation with potential impact
for the key performance will be further
validated by
weblet testing
in our lab plasmid with mutation will be
prepared
tested by our variant id keys and
evaluated
whether the limit of detection
established by the kid
is compromised
the figure here show bgi's second major
genomic surveillance effort for south
cov2
starting from the bottom of this figure
when a patient sample is received we
apply
our rtpcl kit to determine if the sample
is positive or negative for the virus
if positive we can apply our variant id
panel
to identify to identify which string the
virus belong to
next we receiving the sample and use the
genome assembly data generated
to compare the data that already exists
in our database this allow us to
discover
new mutations and also confirm any
mutation
that we already know
here i'm showing the latest update for
our rt pcr kit
we demonstrated that the kit performance
is not compromised by the variance of
concern
and the variance of interest currently
listed by
cdc the lineage string cover those
originated in uk south africa
brazil california and new york
the ethical analysis and functional
validation that i described earlier
conclude our findings
also we achieve a 100 concordant
with our validation and quality
protocols
for all sample tests
bgi have published ie technical notes in
this topic
if you would like to receive a copy of
this document please contact us at
bgi dash discover bgi.com
this slide concludes the part for my
presentation
thank you for attending my talk today
now i will pass my presentation to sabu
from
mgi thanks anthony
and good afternoon to everybody my name
is subbert nimkar
and i will present mgi's kovid 19
extraction solutions port for you
first i will take you through mgi's role
in science kovi 2 testing worldwide
then i will present automated sample
transfer systems
automated extraction systems and mgi's
extraction kits portfolio
and i will end with kovit 19
mobile lab offering that we have
bgi and mgi have been involved
in kobit 19 sequencing almost from the
day one
and we were one of the first one to
sequence the genome
since then we developed
a variety of products that include
extraction case automation system rdpcr
test kits
and in the last year or so
our installations are in over 100
countries
more than 1000 systems running 24 7
and we have enabled customers who are
performing
two million tests per day
our customer base includes both
government entities
as well as private organizations and
they span across
the entire globe which includes north
america
europe south america africa asia china
and oceania mgi plays a role
in an entire workflow for kobe 19
detection
which starts with samples
or swabs in a vtm tube
and ends in an rtpcr test result
mgi offers stp 7000 system
that is capable of sample transfer
then we have extraction systems of two
different types
one performing just extractions
and then the other performing both
extractions and
rtpcr prep we have a range of extraction
kits to support these extraction
automation platforms
and as you heard from anthony
we have a eua for an rtpcr test
and also a variety of variant detection
kits
that we recently launched
going into a bit more detail about the
stp 7000
automated sample transfer system
this is a sample transfer system that
transfers the sample in the vtm tube
containing swab
to a 96 deep well plate
it does decapping of the tube
it does sample accessioning that is
barcode reading
it aliquots the samples or transfers the
samples into a 96 well plate
and then it recaps the tube for
archiving
it is capable of doing 7000 samples a
day
it is a safe system for the operator and
it's equipped with uv and negative
pressure hepa filter
it is capable of handling multiple types
of tubes
which are different dimensions and
different volumes
it is very accurate and it's equipped
with the liquid detection
and it can be connected to any lynx
systems in the lab
here i will quickly demonstrate how
actually this system works
with this using this video in the 7000
system
workflow vtn tubes containing swabs
are loaded on the trays and then trays
are placed
on the deck of the system
the process begins with tubes being
moved
for accessioning by reading the barcodes
once the barcodes are read the tubes are
moved to
a capping decapping station in this
first step
the tubes are decapped once the
decapping is done
they are moved to a deck position where
the sample the vtn
is now aliquoted into the deep well
plate
the tubes are then moved back to
the capping decapping station where they
are
capped and moved back to
the tray the original location
7000 system is the only system that does
everything in one box then coming to the
mgi extraction case
all the extraction kits ngi offers are
magnetic bead based and they follow a
very traditional
workflow in which the samples are lysed
then the nucleic acids bind to the
magnetic beads
then the magnetic beads are washed off
to remove all the contaminants
and possible pcr inhibitors
and then the nucleic acids that are
bound to the
beads are eluted in the aleutian buffer
and this
this way the 96 well plate that's
prepared is ready
for rtpcr prep
we have four different automation
platforms
and they vary in their throughput and
the way they do
extraction so what you see on the left
here
and all the all these platforms uh
support 96 well
they are all uv and hepa filter equipped
they support swabs and many other sample
types and all the consumables and
plastics required for this automation
are supplied by mgi
mjsp960 these are the liquid handlers
so ngsb960ngsp100 these are the liquid
handlers
capable of doing extraction as well as
rtp cr prep
and 960 can do 192 samples in 80 minutes
the systems on the right sp ne32 and any
384
these are as i call it bead handlers
they perform only extraction
i believe any 32 is probably the fastest
extractor on the market can do 32
samples in 9 minutes
and it's a truly plug and play system
any 384 the big brother of any
32 can extract
384 samples in 20 minutes
and i believe this is probably one of
the highest throughput
extractor on the market and again this
system is
also a plug-and-play system
this slide shows you the range of
extraction kits
that enjoy offers and these extraction
kits
are matched with the extraction platform
so 960
384 32 and sd100
i would like to get your attention to
the limits of detection
both njsp 960 and any 384 system
have a limited detection of 100 250
copies per ml as i already mentioned
960 can do 192 samples in 80 minutes
whereas any 384 can do
384 samples in 20 minutes
the input volume is from 160 to 200
microliters whereas output volume
is about 50 micrometers
i would like to take you through one of
the
examples of how we enabled a big
organization like
amazon in their initiative for kobit 19
detection
last year of early fall we got involved
in amazon's initiative and that time the
stated gold from amazon was
at least 50 000 tests across 650 sites
mgi brought in all the tools that
we had at our disposal that included
a bgi's rtp cr test kits ng extraction
kits
mgi automation and more importantly
the applications and service support
our application scientists were involved
in implementation
as well as method modification required
for amazon's need
we trained amazon's lab staff
and we did 24 7 support
and more importantly we ensured that
we have an uninterrupted supply of kids
and consumables with our joint efforts
amazon achieved an
eua that was just recently announced
for their own kovit 19 detection test
for employee testing
our contribution or amazon's choice for
mgi solution
was the following which shows bgi's
rtpcr
kit and mgi's extraction kit
and engines automation for extraction
and pooling amazon's eua
or method includes pooling and then
engineering's 960 system supports
that pooling workflow as well
test sites which are looking for
a faster maybe cheaper alternative
to traction-based rtpcr testing
we at ngi are going to announce
and release a product that will support
extraction-free
pcr test so basically
we are making available a vtm tube that
has a media
that will enable extraction free rtpcr
test
and in this workflow our stp 7000
automated sample transfer system will
transfer the media
that has swab in it to a 96 well
plate and these 96 well plate
containing samples will directly go to
rtpcr test
now it is definitely
faster involves less steps and less
equipment but there is a penalty
and the penalty that we have seen is in
the limit of detection
which is 800 copies per ml
compared to 100 or 150 copies per ml
that we see with extraction
but when we do an apples to apples
comparison of two extraction kits
for example mgi and kyogen we see that
our extraction
free workflow has a lod of 800
whereas kaioshin is thousand copies per
ml
this kit and the vtns will be available
by the end of april this year
lastly mobile lab solutions mgi
offers three solutions for mobile lab
one is a vehicle base a bus based second
is a container and third is
a tent all these setups
have a typical floor plan there are
three functional areas
they're all isolated to prevent
contamination
and these areas are reagent preparation
sample preparation area which also
includes
the automation systems biosafety
cabinets
and an rtpcr testing rules
it has built-in air conditioning and
electrical control room
to to support the entire setup
these installations comply with bsl-2
standards
and they differ based on on the area
or the functionality area in that in
that installation
and all the specs that we we guarantee
uh are mentioned on this slide here
there are different throughput
possibilities they start from
2000 samples per day to
30 000 samples per day these really
depend on the
the footprint of the container for
example whether it's a 40-foot container
or a 45-foot container
and the size of the tent and the number
of
automation systems that are outfitted
in these installations last but not the
least
at mgi we completely understand and
appreciate
the changing and unpredictable future
of kovit 19 testing and our goal
is to enable as many test site
as possible so that we
help manage this pandemic
and put put it behind us
so in that effort mgi is going to
support
testing capacity expansion and to do
this
we are offering automation systems
on a zero dollar release to
to labs who want to either expand
capacity
or whether who wants to set up a new lab
but
do not want to take risk of capital
investment at this stage of the pandemic
so we are trying to help as much as we
can
and we also show these labs that
you will always get a constant supply of
kids consumables plastics
everything that is needed to keep the
testing going
with that i will end my presentation
thank you very much for listening and
anthony
myself julian liu and chris true
are happy to answer questions
okay let's get the q and a started
today i'm also glad that julian knew
and chris true from bgi will also join
our q a session
julin is our field application scientist
based out in montreal canada and chris
is our senior manager of technical
support
based out in bgi's lab in san jose
california
today we have time to answer a few
questions
that came before and during the webinar
to make it easy for everyone i will read
the question
and show them on the screen as i speak
and the first question is you mentioned
the limit of
detection of your rt pcr
south kofi 2 detection kit is unaffected
by the variance of concern
and variant of interest listed by cdc
my understanding is that some of the
reported mutations
are not only in the s gene but also
in some other genes can you comment more
on that hi
this is julian from bgi i can answer
this question
according to the cdc website so far the
key mutations
report for variance of concern are
mentally located
in the s gene of south korea ii but the
target gene
of our bgi sas cov2 detection kit
is located in the orf180e
therefore this reported mutation in s
gene do not affect our kid performance
although
in b117 lineage uk variants
four mutations were also reported in
orf1ab
but only one mutation is relocated
in our target region during the time of
today's webinar recording
our recent functional validation data
demonstrates that plus me expressing
tested mutation
did not compromise the performance of
our assay
so we believe that our saskov2
detection key can be used to efficiently
assess
infection status of individual and help
pandemic control
thank you julian
here is the second question
in your genomic surveillance efforts
tell me more about
the procedure of your red level in
functional validation
and what criteria did you use to
evaluate your results
hey this is chris true from bgi i can
answer this question
as anthony showed in his presentation we
tested
the plasmids with mutations by using our
sars code 2 detection kit
to elaborate we synthesize in vitro the
sequences with
mutations that met our predefined
criteria and we also synthesize sequence
without the target mutation
and these sequences are then expressed
in plasmids
following that we sequence the
synthesized plasmids to verify that the
mutations
are correctly expressed in the plasmids
then we serial diluted the plasmid
without the target mutation
and those plasmids with mutant sequences
at different concentrations
finally we run pcr and compare the ct
values from our experiment
and those values values from the
reference plasmids
if the experimental lod is within three
times
of the lowest lod that we established
then we consider the mutations involved
to have no significant
impact to our kit performance
great thank you chris for your answer
here is the next question can users buy
your sas
cov2 detection kit and variant
identification kit at the bundle with
discount
i understand that the detention kit can
receive the
emergency use authorization from the fda
the bgi planning to submit the
identification kit to the agency
or eua
i can actually answer this question
the discount is certainly available for
our users
but i would say that uh it had to do
with how many kids
one is going to purchase regarding the
question for
regulatory submission of our variant
identification kit
bgi is currently monitoring the pandemic
situation
and will decide if this submission is
necessary
by the way i want to say that our corner
fibers detection kit have received ceivd
so the user should not worry about the
key performance
for our variant identification kit
it is for research use only at this time
and user may validate the key
performance in their clinical lab
for their lab developed tests
to learn more
we have two faq documents on our website
feel free to check them out or contact
one of our reps
it looks like those are the questions
that we have
received so far with that said
thank you very much again everyone for
joining us today
if you have any other questions for this
webinar and our products
please don't hesitate to contact us at
bgi-discover
bgi.com